[Music]
Metro Police holding its third annual
night of power tonight it's actually an
event meant to bring the Muslim
Community and law enforcement together
joining forces to make the valley a
safer place for everybody eight news now
reporter Madison Kimbrough live near the
Summerlin area command where that event
was held tonight Madison
yeah Denise in a world where we've seen
so much division tonight's Gathering
really reminded us that community and
understanding is key no matter where
you're from
when a post-9 11 World we've seen plenty
of incidents where anybody that was
different from the normal has been
targeted but we make it a priority to
give the community a voice Las Vegas
community members and officials coming
together Monday for the third annual
night of power event forgive breakdown
barriers assistant chair of Sasha Larkin
creating this event as a way to unify
the community after the pandemic brought
so much division to people's lives as
well as the continued hate crimes we see
across our nation as well bringing the
Muslim Community and those of different
backgrounds together for a night of
discussion understanding and progression
I think there's a lot of value when you
sit down at the table with people you
normally wouldn't sit and talk to once
we start to build these relationships
and we get to learn about each other's
backgrounds we're more effective as a
Vega strong community
rokai Yusuf Zai is founder of the
Islamic Association of Las Vegas and a
member of Metro's Multicultural advisory
committee he says attending Gatherings
like this strengthens our community and
increases awareness and tolerance a lot
of our officers they're not aware of
different cultures we have classes that
we teach the officers okay so when you
go to somebody's house this is the
things that you should or should not do
the evening was led by Prayer by those a
part of the Muslim faith and concluded
with a meal shared by all reporting live
Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now